this is a film about the hardest kind of
person in the world to break up with a
relationship with them tends to begin
like this you're very drawn to them
perhaps they very much attract you
physically and their personality is
compelling as well you admire them and
in areas feel a lot of sympathy for them
too there's probably something in their
past which really interests and touches
you you have no desire to break up and
in fact you'd love this to last until
the end for their part they seem to be
keen on you that's what they've said on
a number of occasions they show no
interest in leaving you they want this
to be for the long term perhaps forever
and yet there is a problem a problem so
grave and yet so hidden so damaging and
yet so hard to grasp that you can only
bear slowly to face up to it you start
to realize that the partner whom you
love and who says they love you is
having a grievously detrimental effect
on your mental and physical well-being
what wrong might the partner be
perpetrating it can be a spectrum at one
end they might be hitting you but the
spectrum is long and it contains all
sorts of far more insidious ways in
which without ever raising a hand let
alone a finger one human can badly
damage another they might be having
affairs or spending too much money they
might be addicted to something or and
this is properly hard to get a grip on
they may be constantly absent they may
show no reliable warmth towards you but
they may never initiate any touch they
may never even give you so much as a hug
their present but not really they're
probably as soon as these problems first
arose you started to complain but you
did so softly or sarcastically or
bitterly not head-on after all you love
them and you're a good boy or girl it
can take a long time years decades
before you finally dare to find your
voice and come to a place of being able
to raise an adult objection what then
happens when you at last ask these types
to face up to the harm you feel they're
doing to you there are two May
responses both of them are appalling ly
hard to master and probably the second
is the very hardest first they confess
it fed up at last you tell them that
you've had enough of the violence
affairs addiction financial spend
distance lack of intimacy lack of sex
and you raise an ultimatum if they don't
finally raise their game you're going to
be leaving even though of course it's
the last thing you really want you love
them you may be shaking and flushed
after you've spoken you're feeling you
might be crazy after all surely it's
crazy to threaten to leave someone you
love who says they love you you'd
expected all sorts of dark responses on
their part but something that is on the
surface rather lovely now tends to
happen they admit it they confess they
say my goodness you're right I hadn't
really fully realized until now until
you made me finally open my eyes to how
I've harmed you baby I hear you baby I'm
so sorry the person promises that they
will now change they just need a bit of
time they just need your understanding
they suggest getting themselves a
therapist once a month or so and then
they'll get on top of their issues
they're ready candor is deeply moving
and suggests they really do have a
handle on their psyches you are in any
case desperate to believe them they have
a very willing audience indeed the
problem is that despite their promises
the person doesn't change at all they
make a short-term adjustment strong
enough to ensure that you won't leave
them on the timescale you were
threatening but not profound enough to
correct the problem and allow you your
freedom and in the gap between their
promise to change and your realization
that they haven't got the ability or
perhaps intention to do so children may
have been born but they wanted kids to
keep you around you wanted them as a
token of the happy future that was being
promised commitments pile up and there
are fewer options left in the world
beyond you might not be so young anymore
second possibility they deny it
however hideous all the above sounds
there is an even worse kind of
relationship to leave than that and this
is the one with the same
amic's but with one extra twist at the
end when you finally confront them with
the problem they don't confess they deny
it they tell you you're dreaming you're
imagining it the problem lies with you
they say at the same time they get very
incensed and offended at the suggestion
you're making you're so cynical about me
don't you trust me how rude you are
about me why don't you have more faith
in me and in us and they push back
you're just as neurotic as you say I am
the problem is with you not me this is
mind filled territory relationships and
their interactions are generally not
recorded so it's very hard for you to
back up your claims or even be sure of
your verdicts when they're relentlessly
challenged is the loved one spending too
much money
Oh am I just nagging are they actually
flirting or am I just jealous are they
constantly failing to initiate sex or I
just insecure the partner whom you love
and really don't want to leave and who
says they love you ants the difficulty
you faced by enthusiastically telling
you with authority that you really are a
bit crazy that you are seeing things
that you are too demanding that there's
something wrong with you probably you're
an open-minded nice intelligent person
an open-minded nice intelligent people
tend to give others the benefit of the
doubt after all such types no they
aren't perfect they're aware of
everything they get wrong they don't
feel they're brilliant in every way
therefore perhaps it's quite plausible
that here too you may be seeing things
that aren't there why insist
especially when you love your partner
and want to be with them here is a nice
person telling you you're a bit mad and
imagining things
it's a dispiriting message but if
disregarding your impulses and your
emotional needs is the price you have to
pay for keeping a relationship aloft
maybe it's worth it maybe it's worth
thinking of yourself as a bit insane at
least you'll still have a partner so
more time passes and you stay put and in
that time probably there are more
children more entanglement and less of
life left for you to build on afterwards
there is also highly likely to be a
destruction of your sense of reality
you'll probably start to feel as mad as
you're being subtly told you are
you might have a breakdown which isn't
an ideal backdrop against which to leave
anyone all that said in both of the
above cases eventually you will have to
leave your long-term mental well-being
depends on it
but it isn't a picnic having to leave
someone you love who says they love you
and who is either falsely promising to
change or denying they need to change
because you're the defective one to
begin with you will feel extremely alone
with this decision you will be left to
wrestle either with feelings that you
are nasty for leaving someone who is
promising again and again to change all
that you are mad for leaving someone who
tells you you're demented to doubt their
sincerity you will have to destroy a
relationship that might have children in
it on the basis of nothing more firm
than an inner sense that your partner is
doing something seriously deficient to
your well-being and cannot stop
themselves doing it despite telling you
they love you and yet you will have to
leave in order to leave you will need to
think in your mind I'm in love with
someone who is damaged they cannot
realistically change and may even be
using me as a reason not to change or
they're in denial and are abusing my
credulity and self-doubt in order not to
look more honestly into themselves and
you will have to think there is probably
something in my past a history of
putting up with intolerable situations
which makes me a long-term sucker for
this sort of suffering mountain climbers
know that certain peaks can't be climbed
on one's own you need a climbing buddy
and in this context let's call them a
psychotherapist or a very very good
friend the sort who can put in the time
to reassure you of your sanity and who
can be there for you at the inevitable
moments when you feel like you're making
the worst choice in the world
even though despite yourself hating
feelings that you're impatient or
getting everything wrong you are in fact
in the process of taking the very best
decision of your life
deciding whether to stay in or leave a
relationship is one of the trickiest and
most consequential decisions we can face
our stay or leave card game can help us
towards an answer click now to learn
more